hey this is press tow
Walker which number is larger 99
factorial or 50 to the power of
99 I thank vente for the suggestion and
this problem is adapted from the 2021
Chile math
Olympiad pause the video if you'd like
to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this
problem
I'll show two different ways to solve
the problem the first method involves a
clever pairing of the products in the
factorial so 99 factorial is equal to
the product of the whole numbers from 1
to
99 now let's pair 49 and
51 49 * 51 is equal to 50 - 1 multiplied
50 + 1 which is equal to a difference of
squares 50 2us 1 2 we can then pair the
next two numbers we have 48 * 52 that'll
be 50 - 2 * 50 + 2 so that'll be a
difference of squares 50 2 - 2^ 2 we
continue pairing so we have 47 * 53 this
will be 50 - 3 * 50 + 3 and that's equal
to 50 2 - 3^ 2 so so we can continue
pairing all the way to the very last
pair of 1 * 99 which is 50 - 49
multipied 50 + 49 which is 50 2 - 49 2
so how does this pairing help us so we
have 99 factorial which is equal to the
product of these pairs now we can
rewrite each pair as a difference of
squares notice that each of these is
going to be less than than 50 s because
we have 50 s minus some other Square so
we have 49 terms that are less than 50
SAR and then we multiply this by 50 so
we have 50 2ar to the power of 49
multiplied by 50 that will be equal to
50 to ^ of 98 * 50 which is equal to 50
to the power of 99 and that's exactly
what we want to prove 99 factorial is
less than 50 to the power of
99 that's one way to solve the
problem another clever way is to use the
am GM
inequality we have the nth root of the
product of n non- negative real numbers
is less than or equal to the arithmetic
average of the end numbers this is for
non- negative real numbers and equality
holds if and only if all of the end
numbers are equal to each
other so let's take the 99th root of 99
factorial so this will be the 99th root
of the product of 99
terms this will be less than the
arithmetic average of the numbers from 1
to
99 so we need the sum of the numbers
from 1 to 99 this will be 99 multiplied
100 / 2 this is all over 99 the 99s will
cancel out then 100 ID 2 is equal to 50
so this is equal to 50 so the 99 root of
99 factorial is less than 50 raising
both sides to the power of 99 we get 99
factorial is less than 50 to ^ 99 and we
found the answer again now I just want
to close the video with the general
Point let's compare X factorial with 50
to the^ of X in this example 99
factorial was less than 50 to ^ of 99
and it was actually much less so you
might be thinking that X factorial is
less than 50 to ^ x but in fact for
sufficiently large n it will be that n
factorial is much larger than 50 to the
power of n here's one way to see this
take a look at the power series
expansion of e to the power of
50 each term is something like 50 to
the^ of k / K factorial we know this
will converge So eventually the term
terms will have to tend towards zero 50
to ^ k / K factorial will have to tend
toward zero so for some sufficiently
large value of n we will have 50 to ^ of
n / n factorial is less than 1 which
means 50 to the^ of n will eventually be
less than n factorial that's an
interesting little fact thanks for
making us one of the best communities on
YouTube see you next episode of mind
your decision where we solve The World's
problems one video at a
time